Il termine teletrasporto quantistico può sembrare roba di fantascienza, ma come vedremo nell'episodio di oggi
di Qiskit in the Classroom, è una tecnica molto reale e molto utile per la comunicazione e il networking quantistico.
Benvenuto a Qiskit in the Classroom. In questa serie, useremo Qiskit per esplorare alcuni concetti fondamentali
comunemente trattati nei corsi legati al quantum computing. Ogni video è accompagnato da un modulo interattivo
linkato nella descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di darci un'occhiata. Il teletrasporto è ormai un po' un cliché della fantascienza e del fantasy.
Una persona o un oggetto scompare da un posto e appare istantaneamente da qualche altra parte.
Per quanto sarebbe figo, purtroppo, questo tipo di teletrasporto almeno è impossibile. Violerebbe il limite cosmico
di velocità. Niente può viaggiare più veloce della luce. Ma il teletrasporto quantistico è
possibile. Nel teletrasporto quantistico, l'informazione, anziché la materia, può essere trasmessa tra due
luoghi distanti. Hai bisogno solo di una coppia di particelle entangled, una per ciascun sito, e di un modo per comunicare informazioni classiche
tra i due siti. Questo protocollo fu sviluppato nel 1993 da un team
di scienziati quantistici, tra cui Charles Bennett di IBM. Lo chiamarono teletrasporto quantistico perché, analogamente alla versione
fantascientifica, l'informazione quantistica scompariva da un posto e appariva in un altro luogo distante
senza aver mai attraversato lo spazio intermedio. Può sembrare magia, ma come vedremo, non c'è niente
di misterioso o magico in tutto ciò. È reso possibile dal fenomeno dell'entanglement quantistico insieme alla comunicazione
classica. Oggi vedremo il protocollo di teletrasporto quantistico e come funziona. Poi lo metteremo in
pratica su un vero computer quantistico per teletrasportare lo stato di un qubit da un lato di un processore quantistico IBM all'
altro. Ecco come funziona il teletrasporto quantistico. Supponiamo di avere due persone, Alice e Bob, che sono separati
da una grande distanza. Diciamo che Alice ha un qubit. Lo chiameremo qubit Q per comodità. Ed è in qualche
stato quantistico sconosciuto sq, dove alpha 0 e alpha 1 sono numeri complessi.
Alice vuole inviare il suo stato a Bob, ma non ha modo di inviare fisicamente il qubit stesso. Potrebbe essere che
lui sia troppo lontano, o forse non sa nemmeno esattamente dove si trova Bob, quindi non sa dove mandarlo. Per fortuna,
i due amici condividono già una coppia di qubit entangled A e B, dove Alice ha il qubit A e Bob ha il qubit B. E
questi qubit sono entangled. Per entangled intendo che, anche se i due qubit sono separati da una grande
distanza, i loro stati sono correlati in un modo che la fisica classica non riesce a spiegare. Questa coppia entangled è
qualcosa chiamato Ebit, che possiamo usare come risorsa nel quantum computing e nella comunicazione.
In questo caso, Alice può usare l'EBIT come risorsa per trasmettere la sua informazione quantistica a Bob. Per capire come, partiamo
scrivendo lo stato congiunto di tutti e tre questi qubit, dove ho ordinato i qubit in modo un po' arbitrario
per ora, ma questo ordine sarà comodo quando eseguiremo il nostro esperimento su Qiskit. In Qiskit, il modo standard di
ordinare i qubit è da destra a sinistra. Quindi, lo stato del qubit zero apparirà a destra.
Espandiamo un po' lo stato e riscriviamolo così. Poi il primo passo nel nostro protocollo di teletrasporto è
che Alice faccia entangle il suo qubit dati con la sua metà del qubit EBIT usando un gate C-not. Un gate C-not, o controlled-NOT,
cambierà lo stato di un qubit, il qubit target, a seconda dello stato di un altro qubit, il qubit di controllo.
Se il qubit di controllo è nello stato zero, allora non succede niente al target. E se il qubit di controllo è nello
stato uno, allora il qubit target viene invertito. Quindi in questo caso, il qubit dati Q di Alice sarà il qubit di controllo e
il suo qubit Ebit A sarà il qubit target. I primi due termini non sono cambiati affatto con il C-not, ma gli
ultimi due termini sì, perché il qubit di controllo Q era nello stato uno. Poi Alice
applicherebbe un gate Hadamard al suo qubit dati Q, che porta lo stato 0 allo stato 1/2 (0 + 1) e lo stato 1 allo
stato 1/2 (0 - 1). Salterò un po' di algebra semplice qui, che puoi provare a completare da solo se vuoi.
Ma dopo aver riorganizzato alcuni termini otterrai uno stato che ha questo aspetto. Ora lo stato entangled a tre qubit
di Alice e Bob sembra un gran casino. Ma guarda cosa succede se Alice misura entrambi i suoi qubit. Lo stato a tre
qubit collasserà parzialmente in uno di questi quattro
termini. E in ogni caso, Bob si ritroverà con uno stato di sovrapposizione con ampiezze correlate allo stato
iniziale sconosciuto di Alice. Ricorda che le ampiezze sono alpha 0 e alpha 1. Quindi,
ad esempio, se Alice misura entrambi i qubit come zero, lo stato di Bob collasserà in questo termine, cioè lo stato
sconosciuto originale che Alice voleva teletrasportare. Ma se Alice misura zero sul qubit A e uno sul qubit Q, allora lo stato di Bob
sarà questo. Questo stato può essere trasformato nello stato originale del qubit Q se Bob
applica un gate Z, che inverterà questo segno qui. Ma Bob non saprà di farlo
finché non apprenderà cosa ha misurato Alice. Quindi il passo successivo nel protocollo è che Alice chiami Bob e gli dica cosa
ha misurato. Dopo che lo sa, saprà quali operazioni eseguire sul suo qubit per farlo corrispondere
allo stato originale di Alice. Ecco una tabella delle quattro misurazioni possibili e delle quattro possibili operazioni che Bob
dovrà eseguire sul suo qubit in base a quelle misurazioni. Bob potrebbe dover applicare un gate Z, un gate X, o entrambi per
trasformare il suo qubit in modo che corrisponda al qubit originale di Alice. Quest'ultimo passaggio, in cui Alice chiama Bob, tra l'altro, è il motivo per cui
il teletrasporto quantistico non viola la causalità. Anche se lo stato di Bob è collassato istantaneamente quando Alice ha misurato
i suoi qubit, Bob non poteva ricavare alcuna informazione da quello stato finché Alice non gli diceva cosa aveva misurato. E
quella telefonata era limitata dalla velocità della luce. Abbiamo appena passato un sacco di matematica dettagliata, quindi il fatto straordinario
che abbiamo appena teletrasportato informazioni quantistiche potrebbe essersi un po' perso. Ma è davvero incredibile. Usando
l'entanglement come risorsa, Alice poteva fare una misurazione per distruggere l'informazione quantistica conservata da lei e farla
apparire in un altro luogo distante da Bob. Questa distanza potrebbe essere di centinaia, persino migliaia di chilometri. Ancora più
sorprendente, questo protocollo non richiede nemmeno che Alice sappia esattamente dove si trova Bob. Finché condividono un Ebit
e possono comunicare classicamente tra di loro, il teletrasporto quantistico funzionerà. Ora vediamo come funziona
WEBVTT
con Qiskit e teletrasportiamo davvero uno stato quantistico su un computer quantistico.
Partiremo con tre qubit, uno ciascuno per il qubit dati Q e i qubit A e B che formeranno l'E-bit. Iniziamo
creando l'E-bit. Applichiamo un gate Hadamard sul qubit A seguito da un gate C-not
tra A e B per creare lo stato entangled che ci serve.
Poi prepariamo il qubit Q di Alice in uno stato quantistico casuale applicando una unitaria casuale indicata da questa scatola etichettata
U. Poi arriva il teletrasporto. Prima il gate C-not tra i qubit Q e A. Poi il gate Hadamard sul
qubit Q. Poi le misurazioni collassano parzialmente lo stato così che solo il qubit B di Bob è in una sovrapposizione.
Questo è il momento in cui Alice chiamerebbe Bob per dirgli cosa ha misurato. Poi Bob applicherebbe alcuni
gate in base a quelle misurazioni. Queste scatole con bordo rosso indicano gate condizionali. La prima significa
che Bob applica un gate X al suo qubit se il qubit A viene misurato come uno. E
la seconda significa che applicherà un gate Z se il qubit Q viene misurato come uno.
Ora Bob dovrebbe avere un qubit nello stesso stato in cui si trovava il qubit di Alice a questo punto, dopo il gate unitario.
Se tutto è andato secondo i piani, abbiamo teletrasportato lo stato quantistico. Ma come lo verifichiamo? Possiamo eseguire il
medesimo circuit ma con una piccola modifica.
Qui abbiamo aggiunto un'altra unitaria alla fine del circuit applicata al qubit di Bob. Questa unitaria è l'inversa di
quella che abbiamo applicato all'inizio al qubit di Alice. Il ragionamento è che se questo primo gate ha creato lo
stato quantistico che ora è teletrasportato al qubit di Bob, allora quest'altro dovrebbe annullarlo, riportando il qubit di Bob allo stato zero.
Ma ovviamente questo annulla tutto il nostro duro lavoro di teletrasporto dello stato. Quindi non vorremmo
farlo se volessimo davvero fare qualcosa con lo stato teletrasportato, e se fosse davvero in uno stato quantistico sconosciuto
non potremmo applicare una unitaria per annullarlo. In ogni caso, questo è puramente per scopi diagnostici per assicurarci
che il teletrasporto abbia avuto successo. Se misuriamo il qubit di Bob nello stato zero, possiamo essere ragionevolmente
sicuri che il teletrasporto abbia funzionato. Una volta certi che il nostro protocollo funzioni come previsto, potremmo rimuovere questa
unitaria finale e fare davvero qualcosa con lo stato teletrasportato. Ma per ora, verifichiamo solo che funzioni. Eseguiamo
il circuit su un computer quantistico. Possiamo usare il Qiskit primitive sampler per eseguire questo circuit
molte volte e raccogliere statistiche sui risultati delle misurazioni. Se avessimo teletrasportato perfettamente lo stato di Alice a Bob ogni
volta, Bob misurerebbe il suo qubit come zero ogni volta, ma con il rumore ambientale e le imperfezioni nei
gate, ci aspettiamo di vedere alcune esecuzioni in cui il qubit di Bob finisce per essere uno. Ma finché la maggior parte delle
volte il qubit di Bob viene misurato come zero, possiamo considerarlo un successo. Qui abbiamo un istogramma dei risultati delle misurazioni di
tutti e tre i qubit. La misurazione di Bob è mostrata nel primo slot di ogni stringa a tre bit. Come previsto, i quattro
risultati che corrispondono al suo bit uguale a zero sono molto più probabili degli altri quattro. Quindi, abbiamo teletrasportato con successo
uno stato quantistico. Ma guarda quanto lontano abbiamo teletrasportato. Questa è una mappa di tutti i
qubit del processore quantistico che abbiamo usato. E nell'esperimento, abbiamo usato solo questi tre qubit.
Il qubit di Alice era qui e il qubit di Bob era qui. Quindi erano quasi uno accanto all'altro. Avremmo potuto
ottenere lo stesso risultato semplicemente applicando un paio di gate swap, che come suggerisce il nome, scambiano semplicemente gli stati quantistici
di due qubit vicini. Il teletrasporto quantistico è utile per trasportare informazioni quantistiche su lunghe distanze, e
gli stati quantistici sono stati teletrasportati per centinaia di chilometri in passato. Per i nostri esperimenti qui, siamo limitati dalla
dimensione del chip, ma potremmo rendere il teletrasporto un po' più impressionante teletrasportando uno stato tra due
qubit distanti sul nostro computer quantistico. Quindi, proviamoci. Ecco il nostro nuovo circuit diagram. Sembra un po' più
complicato, ma non è cambiato nulla di fondamentale, tranne che ora Alice e Bob creano il loro EBIT condiviso,
poi si separano. Questa serie di linee e X rappresentano gate swap che spostano
gli stati di Alice e Bob da un qubit all'altro. Alice si sposta al qubit 1 e
Bob si sposta al qubit 12. Poi Alice crea il suo stato casuale sul qubit 0 con
questa unitaria. Tieni presente che sta creando lo stato dopo che lei e Bob si sono già
separati. Quindi Bob è già lontano da lei.
Poi il protocollo di teletrasporto continua come prima e Bob si ritrova con lo stato originale di Alice dopo le sue
operazioni condizionali. Applichiamo il gate unitario inverso e poi verifichiamo che il qubit di Bob sia
nello stato zero. E ancora vediamo che la maggior parte delle volte il qubit di Bob viene trovato nello stato zero.
Quindi il teletrasporto ha avuto successo.
Il tasso di successo non è alto quanto quando Alice e Bob erano vicini, però. Tutti quei gate swap
possono essere costosi e causare il degrado dell'EBIT un po'. Il teletrasporto quantistico potrebbe sembrare magia, ma come abbiamo
visto, tutto ciò che serve è l'entanglement, un canale di comunicazione classico e un po' di ingegno. La proposta originale del 1993
che abbiamo trattato in questo video ha posto le basi per altri protocolli come il teletrasporto di gate quantistici
ed è un ingrediente essenziale per il quantum computing e le comunicazioni quantistiche.
Sul fronte sperimentale, gli scienziati hanno continuato a spingere i limiti del teletrasporto quantistico, riuscendo persino a teletrasportare
lo stato quantistico di un fotone tra un laboratorio sulla Terra e un satellite a 1.400 km
sopra di esso. E a teletrasportare stati quantistici attraverso un rumoroso cavo internet classico. Se vuoi teletrasportare il tuo
stato quantistico, vai al modulo di teletrasporto quantistico linkato nella descrizione qui sotto. Grazie per aver guardato
e ci vediamo la prossima volta.